dave chappelle's in big trouble
dave chappelle had a netflix special
dave chappelle mocked the idea that a
boy can become a girl
and now he's in big trouble and there
are protests in netflix and the netflix
ceo initially stood by chappelle but now
he's kind of caving and he's going weak
and
and dave is under the gun so dave
released
a response to the transgender activists
who are demanding his head on a platter
and dave's response was in my view pitch
perfect
to the transgender community i'm more
than willing
to give you an audience
but she will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to but i have some
conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end
you must come to a place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly you must admit that hannah
gatsby is not funny
[Music]
absolutely
right and so the the punch line is what
everyone's focusing on here hannah
gadsby was trending yesterday she is
this woman who did a netflix comedy
special
but the whole
hook of the special was that she wasn't
actually doing comedy
they said she has redefined comedy
because what she said wasn't funny and
it was all just kind of sad
and it wasn't even really supposed to be
funny it was just sad
and so she had redefined comedy and this
was the new comedy and by the way there
was a word for the new comedy it's
called tragedy
the idiot critics
did not know because they didn't know
that word at the time so audiences hated
hannah gadsby's special but the critics
loved it if you look on rotten tomatoes
it's got 90 plus i think it's like 96
critic score and
a very very low audience score then if
you look at chappelle's special it's got
a very low critic score but a very high
audience score that's how you can tell
that dave chappelle is doing a good job
so everyone's focusing on the punch line
you got to do this you got to do this
and you got to admit hannah gatsby's not
funny but the setup of the joke is
what's more important politically this
is i'm not just playing the chappelle
club because he's a funny guy and we can
all get a laugh i'm doing it because
he's got a political lesson here
and the political lesson
is
is throughout and it's really more
focused on the first two things he says
he frames
the debate
chappelle obviously understands politics
so right now he's being protested
there's a lot of money on the line i
mean he gets paid very well for these
specials and if netflix isn't going to
work for them anymore and if the radical
leftists and the lgbt lmnop activists
are are successful then he's not going
to work again and he's going to lose
millions and millions of dollars and
maybe chappelle doesn't care he's a
wealthy guy but i think he wants to keep
doing comedy and so what he does is he
goes listen
i'm i'm willing to talk to you people
sure you you're demanding that you talk
to me he had another funny line in his
response where he said that
transgender people are saying they don't
feel safe he goes i'm the only person
who's not allowed into the netflix
office right now
i'm the only one who's being threatened
here you guys aren't being threatened at
all
but he frames the debate he says i'm
willing to talk to you on my terms
you do it
first of all you have to watch my
special i'm putting a constraint on you
i'm making a demand of you then you got
to come where i want you to come then
you got to do it at a time when i want
you to do it and then you need to admit
this is this is the little cherry on top
and he says you need to admit that
hannah gadsby's not funny what he's
saying is you need to admit that i have
a point
and you need to admit that the people
support me
and you need to admit that the people
support me because i'm right
okay
there's a lot a lot here this is the
reason it's funny i mean you know it's
the old old line from any comedy club
people say it's funny because it's true
well that that's what's going on here
it's dave chappelle's
special and his response are funny
because they're true and there's an
important lesson when you look at the
people who are right now really standing
up in executive positions in politics
whether it's at a comedy special or in
florida or in the united at the national
level
desantis sets the debate donald trump
sets the debate he's always framing the
debate from his point of view whoever
frames the issue
wins the debate hey you
thanks for watching that clip i'm glad
you liked it i enjoyed producing that
clip for you sometimes people are not
told when i i put clips out there i
don't know maybe
our friends here at youtube maybe they
don't always want to tell people one way
you can ensure that that you will get
notifications ring that bell subscribe
the best way to ensure you get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review i'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you